j half is looking to right the ship from
last time out against the reds only
lasted one plus inning
third number 55
first baseman
albert
albert pujols digs in for the first time
back in st louis
there's a cardinal
from 2001 through 11 the numbers
you may never see him again
the 2-1
albert lifts it out to deep left field
he's done it
insane louis he would always rise to the
occasion
and at the age of 41
he hasn't lost his touch
career home run number 679
for albert pujols
unbelievable
are you kidding me
that man has always had a flare for the
dramatic hasn't he wow
it's a bullpen game and it's the fifth
time that corey knobles worked as the
opener four scoreless innings so far in
that role and now it's tyler o'neil
albert pujols with a home run
one-nothing dodgers here in the home
half of the first
and o'neal rips it out to deep right
center bellinger on the move won't get
there
hops over the wall dodgers
uh catch a break
it'll be a ground rule double for tyler
o'neill
one and one on nolan arnado from the
stretch
the former brewer pitches there's a
swing and a drive left field and that's
caught about head high by taylor tagging
up carlson he scores the tying run a
sacrifice fly for nolan arnotto one to
one in the bottom of the first
[Applause]
shaking his hand
good at bat by tyler o'neill with a base
hit into left center
hustling around first thinking two on
his way and in their standing up with
his dynamic speed
fair doubles tonight for tyler o'neill
look at him go same thing we were
talking about this last half finning
with trey turner right off the bat it
looks like a single but when that guy's
running he's thinking too out of the box
tyler o'neill same thing here he gets a
breaking ball down under the zone first
of all talk about the adjustments this
guy has made with off-speed pitches
serves it into the gap nolan arenado is
ready first base is open and hits the
ball hard to left field that's down for
a hit tyler o'neil rounds third he's
headed home and they're not going to get
him
nolan oronato has driven in his second
run of the game
and it's 2-1 st louis
that's the way to get a run with two
outs
double o'neill base it for nolan arnotto
and i'm sure that conversation on the
mountain was uh how are you going to
pitch aronado with first base open
and hanging slider probably was not the
plan but that's what the pitch was and
arenado didn't waste any time
but one of the best pitchers in all of
baseball right now is adam wayne right
yachty base hit into right
gives a little push to
albert pujols
and it looked like souza wanted to throw
to first and yada
yada was having to pick it up and albert
said don't do it
two of the greats in cardinal history
right there yada yada molina and albert
pools yadi now the base hit
to right field he's one for two and
waiting for him at first
alombre
[Music]
seger off second 2-2 flies home a
grounder that ramps off of the mound in
short center field tommy edmond has no
play and will smith is living right
tonight
i'm sure dino eva was pointing at the
bag when corey seeger came over there
because that is a backdoor play to third
base as soon as that ball carrums off
the mound
steven souza in his first game back with
a chance to do some damage down the line
he goes and he has tied this game at the
very least
seeger into score
smith has stopped at third and a double
from steven souza jr
it's 2-2
welcome back to the big souza
one ball no strike pitch to bellinger
the swings hits the ground ball toward
the middle it is grabbed by de young
throws onto first to get him now gets
smith hall and the dodgers have the lead
so productive out for bellinger and the
dodgers lead again it's three to two
justin turner is over two struck out
swinging last time in the third first
time up he lined out to vader in center
turner hits the ball a long way down the
left field line if it stays fair it's
gone it is fair it is gone it's a home
run for justin turner his 22nd of the
season and the dodgers extend the lead
to four to two
look the turner got a pitch to his
liking
because turner came into the series
the previous 19 games
it hit just 226 with one extra base hit
smith is two for two tonight
high fly ball on a high fast ball back
to left o'neal twisting to the wall and
there it goes
skyscraping home run on a high fast ball
from will smith
and a high fastball again
he handles that pitch so well
when they throw him a nasty slider he's
not even close to it and then they think
okay we're gonna go up the ladder and
sneak the heater by him
he's ready for that all the time
cardinals three and a half mets four and
a
half
the percentage drops because you've got
to jump over so many teams
and the hole is short the young loads up
and throws late as three infield hits
for will smith who had seven all year
coming in you put it all together though
it's a bunch of line drives in the box
scoring a four for four game
[Music]
wearing out the shortstop hole
[Music]
[Applause]
his name is not trey turner
but it is will smith and he can run a
little bit
this will be the 10th pitch
[Music]
and it finally finishes him off
a devilish breaking pitch
to get aronado one away in the eighth
got him
same pitch same result
slider for strike three two gone in the
eighth
has been grinding like he
needed to make the team every year
fly to center no big deal for bellinger
and blake trying in with a scoreless
inning even though the lead-off man
reached second
turner up there that's one of the three
dodger home runs
fly ball deep center bader to the track
to the wall the second home run tonight
for turner this one to dead center field
and it breaks it open in the ninth
inning 7-2
[Applause]
you never know when this lineup is gonna
strike and if they can catch some fire
here for the last 24 games this one
included
oh it'll be a fun september
[Applause]
another one too
bouncing ball to second for trey turner
and that will do it
dodger seven cardinals two the dodgers
take the first two of this series in st
louis
you